i mean being from st louis uh like
bob bob gibson and lou brock were
like the first black ball players that i
was really introduced to i'm from
atlanta and
you know hank aaron it you know he was
the brave
a number of of legendary
you know black ballplayers passed away
recently uh hey karen
being the latest hall of famer bob
gibson
hall of famer lou brock hall of famer
that's our legacy
in this sport you have to be great they
were great
and they did it the right way we look at
activism now
we know hank aaron's uh legacy as a
player
but he didn't stop there he was coming
off the likes of
jackie robinson and and and those that
have come before him
and activism i am more than a player i
am more than a uniform
i grew up in temple in his late sixties
early seventies the reds had sprayed
through that happen
but i saw the reds play it i forgot to
meet the morgan
you know him personally um bob gibson i
had many conversations with bob
um hey the first guy that i did a car
show with in 1984
i came up in 84 but became a fan of
baseball like in
69 you know at that time and just
watching the games to my dad
like you said they did it the right way
on the field and off the field
those are my guys when i was around
those guys man people elected me because
i'm gonna watch those cabins and pardon
them with
these guys but like i said those are
true legends
and not only is
two options you got a little league for
oakland babe ruth
and i played oakland babe ruth but i
would always say to myself you know what
why is babe ruth so revered
when hank aaron is the home run king you
know and it would never
you know rest well with me other than
you know obviously the legend of babe
ruth you know
drinking beers eating hot dogs
coming up on one leg and hitting the
ball out the ballpark i mean that's
legendary stuff
but i'm like but hank didn't do that you
know he
stayed the state the course was was an
activist
you know played in milwaukee and then
over
to atlanta and he's the real homerun
king so why we
why are we you know revering you know
babe ruth so much
so my favorite player was ricky
henderson who was chasing lou brooke so
that legacy was just
just always being passed down you know
who was in front of me
who do i have to look up to and what do
i have to chase what is the legacy do i
leave
next you had those guys that we knew
about
bob gibson legendary i mean you let
willie mays tell it
bob gibson you know didn't wear glasses
on the mound on purpose but
off the field he had on glasses so
that's why he was flipping people up and
down and you know willie getting a
high-pitched voice
man you wear glasses
you know all the great legendary stories
so for me
it was you know knowing that
they did it before me knowing their
story and all the things that they went
through
how can i make my mark so i don't
disrespect them
in their legacy because it wasn't about
me
um you know in the uniform yes i'm black
and uniform i have to make my mark but
i'm making my mark because i'm leaving a
legacy i'm leaving
i'm living in their legacy i'm living in
their shadows
you know growing up and and hearing the
stories
from my uncle who my grandfather
who they said my grandfather actually
played against hank aaron
in like some of the before hank went to
like the negro leagues i guess he played
and like
in in uh in alabama and my grandfather
played against whose uncle would tell me
these stories all the time about you
know watching my grandfather and playing
against hank aaron and all this kind of
stuff
so watching what he did um
and actually being able to
get a hank an award named after hank
aaron
is it's surreal because it's kind of
like
i feel like i can't even take this
because of what this man
accomplished like i'm not even on the
same
level or playing field as a hank aaron
to have
755 home runs over 2200 rbis like
that was the bar like and as a power
hitter you're like
well as soon as you get to league i'm
chasing hank ham bro
i'm trying to because that was the bar
that was set like stopping and thinking
about on my my career now
like 382 home runs man that's a lot of
home runs
755 home runs bro like
that is insanity it's insanity to be
that consistent to be able to do what he
did
over the course of his career um it's
what we all strive for
like for me it was kind of like i just
want to do my part to say thank you
for paving the way and that's going to
be me going out here
every single day playing the game the
right way preparing myself the right way
and trying to go out here and do things
to the best of my ability
because that's what you did that's what
these guys did
in bob gibson and hank aaron those guys
lou brock
it's the precedent that's set it's that
pride
of being a black baseball player
to where now it's like it's the
phenomenon of
you know there's there's very few and
far between
but to see kyle to see devon to see some
of these other young black ball players
in the game today
the future is very very bright devin
we'll talk start with you know what is
your history
of the game generally as we get further
and further away from those generations
the less they're talked about
so how did you learn about you know the
greats in the game
um in light of the ones that we've lost
that have passed recently
i mean being from st louis uh like
bob bob gibson and lou brock was
like the first black ball players that i
was really introduced to you know
i grew up watching the old black and
white films of
bob gibson you know striking out 18 or
whatever it was in a game
you know things like that um lou brock
just
you know being the game changer that he
was and all facets of the game
i mean those guys really kind of were
the first ones
to you know that i could see in myself
you know that i'm watching on tv
and i can see the similarities between
us you know
whether you like it or not you just you
pay attention more to people that look
like you
then that kind of led into growing up i
read doc's
autobiography growing up you know he's a
picture on my picture
i identify with him you know and i just
kind of
kept kept it rolling um getting into
like when i actually started playing
then i was following youtube you know
ryan being from st
louis you played shortstop which was
what i played at the time you know i had
to have all your cleats
you know i try to have the batting
gloves you have man like
all this stuff but yeah i mean there's
definitely
it's it's to me it's an honor to be like
one of those guys that some kid right
now is going to be doing the same thing
i'm doing right now
hopefully in 15 20 years
[Applause]
i'm from atlanta and you know hank aaron
did
you know he was the braves you know when
i grew up you know hank aaron was
the gold standard for everything hit
you know being from the south end you
know looking up to him
and he would always you know make
efforts to be around be in the community
and i got the opportunity to meet him
one time and i just remember being
chills going through my body you know
and
so it's you know different experiences
you have
you know throughout your lifetime and
watching you guys you know with the
phillies
you guys legendary runs and screaming at
the tv
and whatnot man these things that
they said they set the table and so i
would run around my house
you know doing you know ryan howard home
run trots you know and uh
trying to see you know how i was going
to celebrate when i cross home plate
things like that so
you know hopefully we can just continue
to be the next in line
in whatever way that may be you know and
that may not be
being the greatest player ever but you
know just in a way that we represent
ourselves
talk to people play the game the right
way you know and wear the uniform the
right way so
i i definitely just try to pick up on
those little things
and uh continue to give my respect
whenever i can but yeah hank aaron was
it was a tough one to see go because
man he was the gold standard really
young gems on here i
know what this game is in some very good
hands i mean if you two
are setting a standard of what it's like
to be a black
baseball player this game is in some
really good hands
if you guys are the future i really love
the way baseball is going
for black athletes and baseball for real
[Music]
you